[Music]
Parliament is made up of groups similar
to political parties in national
legislatures there are currently seven
groups in Parliament plus 57
non-attached or independent members a
group needs at least 25 members from
seven different EU countries the
European People's Party has been the
largest political group in Parliament
since 1999 following the 2019 elections
the EPP has 182 seats
Manfred Weber leaves the group
priorities are clear the other party who
wants to have strictest on border
control there's a readiness to how
people who really need our help they
need fair trade agreements so what REO
bill dimension is for us important and
it's a sterile element we want to create
chops in to say in dialogues European
Union because especially young people
cannot have a future is not just SMD is
also known as the Progressive Alliance
of socialists and Democrats Erica Garcia
Perez chairs the second biggest group of
the Parliament after the EPP they have
154 seats from nearly all EU countries
aside from Czechia and ireland trabajar
a compromiser say con una europa abierta
con una ropa solidary economy or opa
diversa gusta con una europa de las
oportunidades a la gente joven con una
pequeña desig wall dades ssl compromiso
de nuestra familia política euro ant
estos Cinco años vamos a trabajar
pensando siempre en la ciudad an EA
europaea yen como mejor are la vida de
los hombres amou Jerez de ropa 108
members of Parliament's accounted under
the new liberal and democratic group
renew Europe that Angeles leads the
third biggest group in the parliament
their members come from 15 in new
countries so our group is grouped in the
center of the European Parliament
strongly citizens oriented defending
values as freedom individual rights
prosperity in Europe sustainability
in Europe and the balanced economic and
social development the Greens European
free Alliance or greens EFA is a
coalition of four parties led by Phil
ombre and Skaar Keller
they have 74 members and focus on
velocity produced in such a day pretty
hard to associate a pre Democratic
support Lacroix fact Lacroix fever the
ladder in the ecology politically unfit
one for the policy behave identity and
democracy also known as ID is a new
group in the European Parliament set up
after the 2019 European elections they
have 73 members their chair is the
Italian Marcos Annie our motto for the
next five years and for the EU
cooperation will be let's do less
together but better and and trying to
finally show some concrete and positive
result a result on our common policy to
our the European conservatives and
reformists or ECR for short has 62
members from 15 new countries making it
the sixth group in parliament Richard
Lee good co-coach as the group with
Rafaela feet oh the face a wall released
a t-nuts finale vote in parliament Oh in
the poor token in the territory from the
mentally questo mode appointee fair
middle nostril group 1k perky Nosa more
euro realistic normal llamo specially
mullah my tempo states which I'm
abundant again cause it comedy costs
wonder if you don't even know Sturdevant
emilybs when I come the other pro
fundamentalist Arobin the European
United Left Nordic Green left dog way
MGL for short unites 41 members from for
smaller parties with similar political
agendas martinsia divan and man or
oblique co-chair this group the grandeur
is the linker maximum population
parliamentary linker Democratic
opposition here in the house
details of Selig arrest is kind for
friends pretty pure an egg arrested
hundreds political fear how many tea
dimension
the groups will debate scrutinize and
shape European policy for the next five
years
[Music]
you